[Musica]
questa la lista
quello che tiene tra le mani un
portatile con tanto di personalizzazione
per seguire le lezioni da casa questa
foto c'è stata mandata dalla mamma
dell'issa quindi seguente messaggio di
accompagnamento la mia piccolina è stato
giusto aprendosi riprendendosi dopo il
primo matita o le maestre mi dicevano
che finalmente sembrava ad avere la
lista che devono in prima
questa volta spero sia diverso
e grazie a voi riesce a seguire con più
costanza e volentieri le elezioni grazie
per il vostro impegno per l'iniziativa e
per la passione
quel vostro fa riferimento matteo
emanuele pietro e con l'iniziativa apc
fuori punto tech un'organizzazione no
profit che si occupa della raccolta e
della ridistribuzione di dispositivi
usati ma funzionanti visitate gli
studenti di me la lenta non che non ne
dispongono la grafica distanza
l'intero piano si basa su un sito web
che si trova indirizzo
www.micron.com attraverso il quale da
una parte raccogliamo le donazioni da
parte di privati aziende di portatili o
tablet e dall'altra le richieste di
tutte quelle famiglie di milano e
internet che hanno bisogno di un
dispositivo plaid di attica distanza per
i propri figli
attraverso questo progetto che nel 4
abbiamo fondato assieme nel giugno del
2020 all'età di soli 18 anni
se l'uscita coinvolgere positivamente
tante diverse realtà e figura dalla
parte delle donazioni collaboriamo se
con i privati che hanno vecchi
dispositivi da donare se con le aziende
che espose vole intendiamo la necessità
di smaltire grandi quantità di devices
dalla parte delle richieste invece
abbiamo collaborato con oltre 900
famiglie del milanese che a causa di
situazioni particolarmente difficoltose
non possono permettersi di acquistare un
dispositivo ai propri figli
infine sono uscito coinvolge tutti quei
migliaia di italiani non solo che venga
a conoscenza della nostra iniziativa si
sono sentiti felici e orgogliosi della
propria gioventù
dietro lo straordinario percorso che
abbiamo avuto l'onore di intraprendere
attraverso questo progetto se c'era un
processo
profondamente radicato i mie esperienze
personali che agevoli condividere con
voi
tutto parte nel 2013 in prima media
quando in occasione dell'open day della
mia scuola
la professoressa d'inglese invitano gli
studenti avessero ciò che volevo
diventare da grandi e quindi a recitare
una breve frase di fronte i genitori o
[ __ ] ap l'fbi
c'è chi dice l'avvocato dice lo
scienziato che dice al rapper chi dice
il calciatore
io scelgo litro del segno da steve jobs
da grande voglio fare l'imprenditore
per me l'imprenditore già ad 11 anni ne
sono consapevole è colui che fa cadere
le cose
eccoli che contribuisce al bene più
grande della propria comunità facendo
accadere le cose
queste vi è spiccata passione per
l'imprenditorialità e qualcosa che
tuttavia però solo per le pre svariati
anni a scuola alle medie tanto quanto
liceo non sento il bisogno di
condividere questo interesse perché non
lo ritengo funzionale alla sfera
personale e accademica che costituiscono
la mia vita
in parole povere e parlare di pinto
realità mi mette in imbarazzo non mi
sento mai all'altezza e penso che
comunque vada nessuno capirebbe
e ci sono voluti sette lunghi anni per
trovare il coraggio di condividere
questa mia passione è quello che
accaduto dopo ha dell'incredibile ma
come facciamo un ulteriore salto in
avanti e giungiamo al 2016 quella selva
di iscrivermi in uno dei licei
scientifici più difficili non solo carne
città a milano ma anche dell'intero
paese al terzo nonché ultimo anno che
passa in questa scuola in parole delle
lezioni più importanti della mia vita mi
rendo conto che io sentirsi felici la
mia felicità la mia serenità non possono
dipendere dalla mia capacità di aderire
ad uno strato educativo che deviano
studente capace di ottenere il massimo
dei voti in ogni singola materia mi
rendo conto che non fa per me investire
ogni singolo frammento del mio tempo
allo studio con l'obiettivo di adire da
ad un futile stereotipo inizio invece
valorizzare la mia capacità di
bilanciare la mia sfera personale con
quella accademica
mi rendo conto che il traguardo più
grande che io mi possa porre sempre di
ottenere un ottimo equilibrio interiore
il ricordo infatti quei momenti mi hanno
fatto sentire più realizzato nel corso
di quell'anno sono stati quelli in cui
sono uscito investire del tempo nello
sport oppure negli amici ottenendo
comunque voti alti uno scola
particolarmente tosta
questa mia nuova scoperta del messe a
dura prova nel 2019
yuri trasferirmi in inghilterra
presentare gli ultimi due anni del mio
percorso liceale
intorno un contesto totalmente
differente rispetto quello cui ero
abituato da un punto di vista accademico
possa ricevere tra il 57 voti
settimanalmente al 23 per ogni materia
nell'arco di un intero trimestre non ho
più la sicurezza con fredda da un ciclo
continuo di feedback e devo pertanto
arrangiarmi
capisco quindi che miccoli va interiore
non solo di vedere la mia capacità di
bilanciare le diverse sfere che
compongono la resistenza ma anche della
mia abilità di valutare mio impegno
senza che ci sia necessariamente
qualcuno dall'altra parte capace di
attraverso i voti indirizzarmi sulla
retta via
d'altra parte partire da questo momento
la consapevolezza dell'importanza del
mio libro interiore mi dalla licenza di
credere nei miei mezzi e dalla licenza
di credere nel mio potenziale
licenze di credere da solo nelle mie
capacità
l'esperienza inglese importa un altro
grande insegnamento
la mia scuola in particolare mi fanno
presente un certo numero di giovani
musicisti tutti molto in gamba tra di
loro c'è anche un mio amico italiano
chitarrista che esattamente come me ha
scelto di frequentare gli ultimi due
anni dell'ice lontano da casa
nel corso della parte iniziale della
ventura ogni strumento internazionale
trovare proprio i modi di integrarsi con
la loro comunità paolo è così che si
chiama l'amico ha trovato un metodo
unico ogni settimana si ritrova con i
suoi colleghi musicisti nell'aula di
musica e suona con loro jazz ogni volta
che esce da queste jam session
o meglio performance musicali
improvvisate
l'ho trovato si alza come non mai sono
quindi di parteciparvi incuriosito
nonché affascinato anche da agenda quale
tanto solo particolarmente appassionato
e li
capisco tutto
colgo il significato di passione
condivisa tocco con mano la magia che
sica tra persone che condividono
l'interesse milano contro della miriade
di opportunità perse fino a quel momento
cercando di nascondere la mia più grande
passione a coloro che avrebbero potuto
valorizzarla
capisco che esternare le proprie
passioni non è futile ma anzi non può
che contribuire alla crescita delle
medesime
facciamo un altro passo in avanti
e arriviamo al maggio del 2020 con
l'idea di creare un sito web che
permetta a chi disco di tempi di donarli
e kimi ce ne ha bisogno la gatti che
l'istanza di riceverli quando l'idea di
fondare l'iniziativa no profit che si
occupa esattamente di questo cosa faccio
nella prima volta nella mia vita scelgo
di condividere la mia più grande
passione
sotto forma di bozza per un progetto con
qualcuno di fuori di me stesso
ne parlo con matteo nei suoi occhi
conosco immediatamente con la scintilla
lo stesso entusiasmo che aveva visto
nelle dita di paolo mentre si muovevano
freneticamente sulla sua chitarra
l'entusiasmo non può che nascere
ulteriore entusiasmo e io ci credo nel
progetto perché viene da nel mio e
quindi nel suo potenziale ne parlano che
con emanuele ed è anche lui entusiasta
anzi emanuele così entusiasta che esce
addirittura a trasferire questa sia
questo suo sentimento a pietro decide di
prendere parte del progetto senza
conoscere né me né tantomeno matteo
eravamo gruppo giovanissimo con le idee
molto poco chiare ma con tanta tanta
voglia di buttarsi nel corso delle
nostre prime chiamate su google mit
tutto ciò si percepisce ma secoli anche
un grande entusiasmo nel momento più
fatto esperienza di con entusiasmo che
discuti questa e la strada giusta da
percorrere
abbiamo creduto così tanto nell idea di
credere nei propri mezzi che abbiamo
fondato un'iniziativa che si occupa
esattamente di questo dare ai giovani
gli strumenti i mezzi per credere del
proprio potenziale
attraverso l'esplorazione del mondo
straordinario offerta dal digitale e noi
quote o come gruppo come pc furio punto
tech condividiamo la filosofia di fondo
che abbiamo cercato di rispecchiare il
nostro progetto fare del bene in modo
sostenibile dove fare del bene
vuole dire impattare positivamente la
società in senso allargato gli studenti
le famiglie le aziende l'ambiente le
scuole le mamme i papà
a 11 anni volevo fare l'imprenditore
voglio ancora fare l'imprenditore sia
chiaro ma differenza di otto anni fa
oddio consapevolezza in più
uno
la sala da percorrere se questa quella
dell'imprenditoria sociale quella della
sostenibilità quella del fare del bene
dell'innovazione delle regalare
opportunità del digitale
due che non sono l'unico ad avere queste
cose consapevolezza
lo sa anche matteo lo sa anche manuel e
lo sa anche pietro e da oggi mi auguro
anche qualcun altro
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]